[Aplausos]
[Música]
japón contra corea corea contra japón
japón contra china china contra japón
korea contra china china contra corea y
mientras tanto corea del norte y taiwán
por ahí en medio queridos amigos el este
de asia se ha convertido si es que no lo
ha sido siempre en todo un invernadero
de enfrentamientos y crisis diplomáticas
entre los tres vecinos más poderosos de
la región china japón y corea del sur
unos conflictos que en ocasiones desde
el ojo occidental nos pueden parecer
casi ridículos pero que nace oriental
son mucho más que simples conflictos
territoriales de hoy estas islas son
mías y no tuyas islas que por cierto en
algunos casos como veremos un poco más
adelante ni siquiera lo son el problema
por llamarlo de alguna forma es que esta
parte del mundo junto a la cuestión
territorial se mezcla también un
componente de honor nacionalismo y
sentimiento de autodefensa que tiene
mucho que ver con el pasado del siglo 20
de hechos que ocurrieron hace menos de
80 años
[Música]
durante la primera mitad del siglo 20
japón llevó a cabo en asse oriental y
también en el sudeste asiático una
agresiva campaña para expandir su
imperio cuyo comienzo muchos fechan en
1904 con la guerra ruso-japonesa y que
finalizó con la capitulación del imperio
de japón en 1945 esa expansión imperial
se llevó por delante decenas de millones
de vidas incluidas las de millones de
personas civiles que perdieron la vida
en numerosas masacres ataques
indiscriminados ejecuciones experimentos
con humanos y un sinfín de salvajadas
que luego más tarde fueron reconocidas
como crímenes de guerra yo es que esta
campaña expansionista supuso la
ocupación de numerosos países aunque en
principio tras la caída del imperio de
japón se firmó el tratado de san
francisco de 1951 que reguló la
devolución de todos los territorios de
las ex colonias a sus respectivas
naciones ciertos vacíos legales y
ambigüedades han hecho que japón reclame
como propios algunos de ellos
en cierto modo amigos esto es lo que
explica aquí algunas de las víctimas del
imperio japonés saquen las garras cada
vez que el país nipón dice que sea que
el territorio o por es el suyo claro que
ese no es el único motivo el creciente
peso de china y la feroz lucha por cada
metro de las zonas económicas exclusivas
también han alimentado muchos de estos
enfrentamientos políticos
[Música]
los casos más sonados son los de las
islas senkaku que japón se disputa con
sim y taiwán los islotes doctor de corea
del sur y con bastante menos ruido
mediático también parte de las islas
kuriles de rusia así como okinotori cima
este lugar okinotori sima es un sitio
del que por cierto seguramente nunca
habréis oído hablar pero que tiene una
curiosa historia detrás amigos en este
vídeo os vamos a contar en qué consisten
exactamente todos estos conflictos
territoriales que en algunos casos han
puesto al rojo vivo las aguas que
separan a japón de china corea del sur y
rusia atentos porque en esta historia
hay mucha más tela que cortar de lo que
podríamos imaginar así que arranquemos
[Música]
senkaku el conflicto fabricado
amigos alguna vez habéis oído hablar de
las islas senkaku o suena quizás más un
hombre chino liu a los que nos veis de
occidente que seguís la gran mayoría es
probable que no suene ni el uno ni el
otro sin embargo en la se orientan la
cosa es muy pero que muy distinta
[Música]
las islas senkaku son un grupo de cinco
islas y 3 rocas completamente
deshabitadas que se encuentran entre
japón taiwán y la china continental la
más cercana a los tres países se
encuentra en una estratégica posición a
170 km de taiwán a 170 km de la isla
japonesa de ishigaki ya 330 kilómetros
de la costa china al igual que tantas
otras islas de la zona con la reconoció
como territorio propio justo antes de
empezar su expansión militar en 1895
cuando la estrategia de japón consistía
en ir reclamando territorios deshabitado
se islita relativamente próximas y es
que la senkaku nunca hubo más de 200
habitantes fundamentalmente pescadores
que aprovechaban los ricos caladeros de
la zona
[Música]
de todas formas lo curioso de esta
historia no es tanto como los japoneses
reclamaron su soberanía sino lo que
hicieron después el imperio de japón
privatizó las senkaku en 1932 cuando se
las vendió a la familia coca que
pretendía establecer un centro de
producción de comida sin embargo en 1940
su proyecto pues fue a pique y tras la
derrota japonesa en 1945 las islas
pasaron a estar administradas por eeuu
que también administra todo japón hasta
sin embargo estas islas se quedaron bajo
dominio norteamericano hasta el año 72
ese año no sólo la senkaku fueron
devueltas a la soberanía japonesa sino
que también cuatro de esos islas fueron
compradas por otra familia distinta la
familia kurihara y amigos exactamente
ahí fue cuando empezó todo el lío con la
devolución de las islas por parte de
eeuu a japón china y taiwán
paralelamente empezaron a reclamar como
suyas en base a su proximidad ya una
disputa histórica sobre la delimitación
marítima realmente de ser así las islas
pertenecerían a taiwán pero claro como
la china comunista no reconoce a taiwán
como un país por la reclamaron como
propias pero al fin y al cabo hablamos
de unas islas deshabitadas aparentemente
sin mucho interés así que el conflicto
diplomático y territorial se quedó
dormido con el paso de los años sin
causar mayores problemas hasta que en
2012 de repente despertó de nuevo
resort ahora bien que creéis que pudo
pasar en 2012 para que de repente el
problema de las senkaku se reavivara
pues japón decidió nacionalizar las
islas y nacionalizar las se las compró
de nuevo a la familia publicará y
convirtió la protección del archipiélago
en todo una prioridad nacional ampliando
incluso las unidades militares
desplegadas alrededor de ellas esto hizo
que ese año china ya es un avión de
vigilancia marítima sobrevolar el
espacio aéreo de las islas por primera
vez desde 1958 y no sólo eso las
inclusiones chinas y las respuestas
japonesas con actos similares han sido
una constante desde entonces y de hecho
están viviendo un punto álgido en el
momento de preparar este vídeo con
barcos de los guardacostas chinos
navegando regularmente alrededor de
estas islas
ahora bien qué es lo que ha conducido a
china a ampliar su presión y vigilancia
sobre las en kaká pues sorprendentemente
cosas como estas
votación en japón para cambiar el
estatus de unas disputadas islas amenaza
con aumentar las tensiones con china
el ayuntamiento de ishigaki en la
prefectura japonesa de okinawa aprobó la
legislación que cambia el estatus
administrativo del grupo de islas
deshabitadas conocido como las senkaku
en japón el proyecto de ley cambia el
nombre de las islas con fines
administrativos de tonos ciro a tonos
sirios hán kaku un cambio de nombre
aunque parezca mentira básicamente un
simple cambio de nombre por parte de un
ayuntamiento bastó para desatar todo un
choque diplomático la isla diaoyu y las
islas afiliadas son el territorio
inherente de china china está decidida a
salvaguardar nuestra soberanía
territorial esta llamada red designación
administrativa es una grave provocación
hacia la soberanía territorial de
chinatown li jian portavoz del
ministerio de relaciones exteriores de
china no me digáis que no parece que así
una broma pues amigos así se las gastan
en asse oriental
el caso es que legalmente con la ley en
la mano no cabe ninguna duda y que las
islas senkaku son actualmente territorio
japonés y las reclamaciones de taiwán y
china pues no parecen tener mucho
recorrido aunque claro con la semana del
siguiente importe nunca se sabe sin
embargo como os comentábamos al
principio del vídeo este no es ni de
lejos el único conflicto territorial que
japón tiene abierto el otro confín
importante por ejemplo es el de los
islotes doctor que implica directamente
a corea del sur un país con el que como
sabéis japón se lleva como el perro y el
gato así que atentos
[Música]
no son las islas es nuestro honor en el
mar del este entre la península de corea
y japón se encuentra doctor apenas dos
islotes y un puñado de rocas que sin
embargo se han convertido en uno de los
símbolos patrios más característicos de
corea del sur pero como demonios se
pueden haber convertido unos pedazos de
roca en mitad del mar en los que no se
puede hacer prácticamente nada en toda
una especie de símbolo moderno de
resistencia anti japonesa pues bien para
entender todo este asunto creo que
tenemos que echar un vistazo a la
historia
e
los islotes dokdo también conocidos
internacionalmente como rocas del yang
curp o takeshima en japonés aparecen
mencionados en escritos antiguos que
mencionan que los islotes pertenecían a
corría ya desde el año 512 durante el
reino coreano de siria en 1905 durante
la guerra ruso-japonesa el imperio de
japón los ocupó y poco después en 1910
fueron anexionados como el resto de
corea como territorio propio del imperio
es por eso que para los coreanos doctos
simboliza la primera víctima de la
ocupación japonesa de 1910 y para ellos
forma parte de los territorios
colonizados durante esa época
el caso es que nuevamente tras la caída
del imperio en 1945 estos islotes
quedaron de nuevo en manos coreanas o al
menos eso era lo que creían los coreanos
sin embargo para los japoneses esto era
más que terra nullius o sea tierra de
nadie' y por tanto si las podrían
reclamar ahora bien acaso con la
descolonización de corea y la disolución
del imperio de japón no se fijó el
futuro de las doctos pues bien miras lo
que decía el artículo 2a del tratado de
san francisco
japón reconociendo la independencia de
corea renunció a todo derecho título
reclamación sobre corea incluyendo las
islas de que el parc por hamilton o la
galette artículo 2a del tratado de san
francisco como seguro que os habéis dado
cuenta estas rocas pues no están
mencionadas expresamente en el tratado y
ese es el vacío legal que aprovecha
japón para continuar reclamando los
islotes por este motivo los argumentos
para defender la soberanía coreana de
estos islotes giran básicamente en torno
a los debates históricos geográficos e
incluso geológicos ya que según
defienden los coreanos forman parte de
la plataforma continental de la isla
surcoreana de bullock está a unos 94 km
mientras que las islas japonesas más
cercanas las islas
y están a 157 km del auto el caso es que
igual que vivimos con las senkaku el
conflicto diplomático sobre todo está
sorprendentemente más vivo que nunca en
parte gracias a cosas como estas un mapa
de 156 años de antigüedad puede reavivar
la disputa entre japón y corea del sur
sobre unas islas en ese mapa de 1861
docto apareció dibujado como parte del
reino de corea el mapa había estado
oculto hasta 2017 como parte de la
colección de un particular japonés y
paradójicamente japonés que lo adquirió
en 1932 anteriormente pues había estado
en la biblioteca de pyongyang
[Música]
otro documento del gran consejo del
estado de japón datado en 1877 decía que
todo no tenía ninguna relación con japón
sin embargo amigos hay para todos los
gustos mapas coreanos donde donde
aparece dibujado como territorio coreano
y otros japoneses que lo incluyen como
parte de la prefectura de shimane todo
esto ha conducido a un cierto mito sobre
quién debe controlar los islotes y en
japon al menos en la prefectura de
shimane se lo toman bastante pero que
bastante en serio de hecho el gobierno
de la prefectura declaró el 22 de
febrero como el día de takeshima y cada
año hay actos y eventos que reclaman la
soberanía sobre todo una propaganda que
no solo es japonesa sino también
surcoreana aunque nos pueda parecer
surrealista ambos gobiernos se gastan
millones de dólares cada año en
promocionar la soberanía sobre estos
islotes tienen páginas web
institucionales de sus respectivos
ministerios de exteriores donde tratan
de explicarlo todo e incluso ponen
anuncios en las calles o en el método si
vamos que seguro que puede que os
parezca que en esta zona del mundo se
cogen las cosas con papel de fumar y
desde luego pues que os voy a decir no
os falta razón menudos conflictos estos
sí que son ganas de pelear ahora bien en
control a estos islotes al día de hoy
pues amigos
hoy por hoy corea del sur
[Música]
corea del sur mantiene un contingente
militar rotatorio de 39 efectivos que
está desplegado permanentemente en estas
islas e incluso cuentan con residente
claro que oiga anciano que podría tener
que abandonar la isla muy pronto para
conseguir acceso a tratamientos médicos
lo más curioso de todo es que estos
policías que hay en doc docx suelen ser
chicos del servicio militar obligatorio
que eligen este lugar para no tener que
hacer prácticamente nada aunque eso sí
tampoco tiene nada que hacer porque en
estos islotes lo único que hay es un
pequeño embarcadero un puesto de guardia
un faro un buzón de correos y un par de
senderos nada más
el caso es que japón lleva años
proponiendo someter esta disputa a la
decisión de la corte internacional de
justicia de la ya cosa que seúl pues
rechaza porque para ellos eso sería como
asumir que existen dudas sobre la
soberanía de un territorio o que bajo su
punto de vista fue ocupado por la fuerza
ahora bien llegados a este punto seguro
que muchos os estáis preguntando pero
qué narices hay en doctor para que
despierte tanto interés en ambos países
qué demonios justifique un despido de 39
soldados o que los ministerios de ambos
países pierdan un solo minuto con esta
historia pues amigos aquí la cosa se
pone interesante
[Música]
algunos reportes hablan de un enorme
depósito de gas situado en esta zona un
enorme depósito que podría llegar a
suplir todas las necesidades de gas de
corea del sur durante un periodo de
entre 30 y 100 años y no olvidéis que
con el sur es un importante consumidor
de gas natural por cierto como
curiosidad sabéis que donde fue
bombardeado en una ocasión y no no fue
japón sino eeuu en 1948 el ejército
norteamericano realizó aquí unos
ejercicios aéreos de prácticas de tiro
con misiles que acabaron muy pero que
muy mal resulta que justo en el momento
de los ejercicios se encontraban unos 80
barquitos pesqué dos surcoreanos
recogiendo algas el suceso terminó con
16 coreanos muertos y la imagen del
ejército americano por los suelos pero
amigos para terminar no nos gustaría
cerrar este vídeo sin hablaros del
curioso caso de honor y sima una isla
que bueno ni siquiera lo es atentos
las disputas sumergibles a ver qué
pensaríais si os digo que japón dedica
sustanciales recursos diplomáticos a
reclamar unos islotes unos peñascos en
pleno mar de filipinas que apenas
sobresalen de unos 20 20 centímetros
sobre el nivel del mar y que suman un
área de apenas 0,000 8 kilómetros
cuadrados que como os quedáis
[Música]
hablamos de okinotori sima un arrecife
de coral administrado por japón que está
perdido en medio del mar con dos rocas
que han sido elevadas con hormigón para
evitar que se sumerja con la marea alta
es algo surrealista algo así como un
intento desesperado por conservar unas
rocas que muy probablemente hubieran
desaparecido bajo el mar de no ser por
el hormigón y la pregunta es porque que
te lleva a colocar una pila de hormigón
sobre unas rocas en mitad del mar pues
bien todo esto tiene una explicación
amigos japón quiere que se le reconozca
un área económica exclusiva alrededor de
estas rocas de 200 millas náuticas unos
370 kilómetros el mismo que le toca a la
costa de cualquier país continental oa
islas pobladas y consolidadas la
intención de japón en este caso es solo
apagar esta zona con la zona económica
exclusiva de china para así poder
robarle un pedazo de este pastel si es
que los chinos se fueran a dejar claro
claro que para casos como este donde
hablamos de islas deshabitadas la
legislación internacional solo le
reconoce 12 millas náuticas o 22
kilómetros de zona económica exclusiva
por cierto por si no lo sabéis en estas
zonas económicas exclusivas los estados
tienen exclusividad para gestionar y
extraer los recursos por ejemplo
minerales o pesqueros que consideren
oportunos es decir pueden usar el área
como les dé la gana de hecho esto de las
zonas económicas exclusivas tienen mucho
pero que mucho que ver con todas las
disputas que hemos visto en este vídeo
normalmente los países claro tratan de
que es una económica exclusiva pues si a
lo más grande posible pero claro el caso
del quinto honor y sima es no sé cómo
describirlo el sueño del rey de los
pícaros algo por cierto parecido al caso
del yodo
e
yodo también llamada roca socotra es una
roca sumergida a 46 metros de la
superficie que se encuentra entre china
y korea está administrada de facto por
este último país corea del sur con la
intención de que se le reconozcan
derechos de zona económica exclusiva
coreas sobre esta roca el gobierno
construyó en 2003 una plataforma de
investigación oceánica sujeta a la
propia roca sumergida donde no falta la
bandera surcoreana que marca su
propiedad el tema de yodo puede parecer
quizás uno de los más surrealistas de
este vídeo porque la roca ni siquiera
son al aire libre pero no es más que un
ejemplo más de cómo los tres grandes
países de asia oriental china corea del
sur y japón intentará dañar zonas de
influencia sea como sea y de pasos y
recursos minerales gas un buen caladero
de pesca como parece que es el caso pues
mejor que mejor
en fin amigos estas son las principales
disputas territoriales en las aguas de
los mares que rodean a japón y que
aunque nos puedan parecer conflictos
ridículos que el hecho es que alimentan
choques diplomáticos que en ocasiones
ponen la tensión al rojo vivo con
despliegues militares amenazas de
sanciones y el riesgo de que por
cualquier tontería las cosas se vayan de
madre todo por mantener alto el orgullo
nacional y de paso expandir las zonas
económicas exclusivas en fin espero que
ahora cada vez que escuchéis hablar de
todas estas polémicas pues sepáis
exactamente a qué se refiere y ahora sí
y si este vídeo os resulta interesante
no olvidéis darle al botón de like
suscribiros abisal político una vez más
muchas gracias por estar ahí un saludo
hasta la próxima
[Música]